you had mentioned you had worked with
chuck berry for 30 plus years yes
chuck berry johnny be good you know what
else
uh who else or what else both what are
your favorite songs from uh
from chuck berry what'd you play with
him and and what other artists
i played all this hits with him um
johnny be good rollover beethoven sweet
little sixteen ninja
maybelline carol school days all of them
amazing so much monkey business
i mean you know johnny b is my favorite
song uh from chuck
and it's my favorite song of all time uh
also like little richards uh i like
anything he did
but my favorite little richard would be
uh lucille good god i miss molly
i love jailhouse rock by elvis
hard-headed woman
when you saw the scene you've seen i
assume back to the future when michael j
fox did johnny be good
you know i was a kid when that movie
came out that melted me i love that
anytime that movie comes on i mean do
you see that scene that must have
like what did that do to you when uh
michael j fox did that
it was a great scene it was written it's
a scene that everybody remembers from
that movie
of course you know of course let me ask
you a thoughts
and that's the power of that chuck berry
rock and roll of course
you know it only took up a couple
minutes in the movie but it it is the
most memorable scene of the movie
and the whole movie was great but that
is the scene that sits out
just like pulp fiction remember that
movie of course
yeah exactly and what and what song were
they uh playing
that was chuck berry uh chuck berry yeah
cllv yeah exactly is that chuck berry
music
wow it jumps out at you well you had
once said
that chuck berry perhaps was the
greatest civil rights hero
in america i want to say the greatest
but was a civil rights hero
because because of him white white
people or
black people white kids black kids had
danced together
for the first time in american history
is that right
because of the music he created right
and the other artists played it as well
but but they would not be playing it had
it not been for creating it of course
uh elvis you know elvis presley jerry
lee
lewis bill haley in the comments carl
perkins buddy holly
all these people uh as well as little
richard bow diddly fast
swing music yeah
that was a group for swing right rock
and roll
you know that back beat right you got me
moving over here daryl
yeah so he took that that swing music
you know in the blues and country and
put a bath beat on it that boogie woogie
with the backbeat
right that became rock and roll and and
back to the future
he called there's a scene when he when
michael j fox is playing
and i forget the guy's name but he says
you know that new sound you're looking
for
well get a listen to this boom and he
puts it in the guy oh wow
that's what that new sound was that's
great and michael j
fox said you might not be ready for this
but your kids are going to love it
right exactly you know it's prophetic
right right and just like the you know
chuck berry wrote a song called rock and
roll music
and everybody's covered everybody likes
that rock and roll
music right any old time you choose it
you use it
yeah it's got a what it's got uh
it's got a bat beat you oh you gotta
back
okay all right i just failed that test
but i know the song yeah
respect rock and roll music i love that
a back beat you can't lose you got a bat
what are you talking about
amazing last question on music before we
move on to
you know more serious topics uh my
favorite artist
you know i love all sorts of music i
love sinatra i love hip-hop today
i love hall and oates i love you know
johnny be good all that
uh what are your thoughts on jackie
wilson
oh man one of the greatest singers of
all time
uh elvis loved him in fact in las vegas
he was known as the black elvis
even though he was doing that before
right it's always
so i learned about jackie was i love old
movies i learned about jackie wilson
and for our audience that doesn't know
who he is there was a
famous scene in uh coming to america
eddie murphy
where he's shouting from the rooftops do
we love
to be loved oh what a feeling to be
loved
and i remember like these who is that
singer who is that person i found that
it was jackie wilson
and for some reason he's not as famous
as
elvis as chuck berry
as james brown why is that because he
does he has so many amazing songs
it's not for some reason there's a
reason why tell me why
the reason is racism you know you only
let a few
black people slip through the brats you
don't want too many of them
jackie wilson was a good looking uh
black guy yep he had
you know women went crazy over him
right and white women were not immune to
that
you know some you know what's good
looking is good looking what sounds good
sounds good
regardless of color and you know and
that
that was a big concern back then little
richard got away with it
because little richard was gay so people
were not you know
so so worried about their women going
after you know this gay man
all right but you know you think about
it you think about like this also
when well when you know when i was
coming up there were no black idols on
tv
uh i you know who did i have to relate
to i had to relate
you to little opie taylor in mayberry
you know
andy griffith ship and hope he didn't
have any black friends i watched leave
it to beaver
little beaver cleaver and wally cleaver
they didn't have any black friends
i watched lost in space you know space
family robinson
with their crazy robot you know they
went all over the universe
he went to other universes and no black
people no black people
it's all green people right with the
forearms
freaking ridiculous so everybody they're
seeing aliens but not black people
you know how freaking absurd that is
yeah by today's standards
yes but that's what i had to grow up
with all right
so then um the first
and there were no of course there were
no black superheroes that's why it was
it's such a big thing
that that this person would just die
black panther of course chadwick boseman
of course
exactly you know yeah so i mean who were
my heroes back then
batman superman aquaman
you know wonder woman you know all these
people but who what were they they all
were white
right so so the i mean you you had
a couple or most shows that featured any
black people
they were in a subservient role as a
butler
you know made the bothered you know a
pimp a drug dealer in the movies or
whatever
uh but then you know when we got some
better roles
they were never top uh you know they're
always secondary
um so let's say i spy with uh bill cosby
and robert cook
they were partners in that in that tv
series uh but but one was not higher
than the other
uh then we saw lieutenant uhura in uh
starting the original star trek with uh
william shatner
and that was the first interracial kiss
on tv what year was that
i think 1969 right so all throughout the
60s there's nothing like that going on
exactly so into the 70s when did shaft
come out uh i think when maybe in the
late 70s
late 70s maybe mid to late 70s so who
was the first
you know you said there was only white
superheroes who's the first black person
you saw on tv you're like all right i
like that guy
or gal oh yeah okay well he uh he he was
a hero
uh he wasn't a superhero it was super
powers but
he was you know a badass uh that was mr
t
mr t yeah of course mr t but when was
that
that was on the 18th what was that but
that was not until the early 80s though
right
exactly exactly it took up until the
early 80s until a superhero badass dude
showed up on the scene mr t right
exactly and what did they pick
for uh for that they picked the ugliest
black guy they could find mr z
yeah gold chains galore yeah they never
you know
and his mohawk park put a denzel
washington
or a uh billy d williams or some you
know good looking black guy
up there because again that would
attract you know the females
and so you know you know what female in
their right mind is going to be
attracted to mr g
mr t is not going to be happy when he
sees this darrell let me tell you
[Music]
something